voilà mesdames et messieurs bonjour
en réalité vous avez vu le seul geste
que le sache faire à la campagne je suis
affreusement maladroit de mes mains je
le regrette
c'est un de mes graves défauts je ne
sais ni circuler et rose ni m'occuper
des arbres fruitiers ni même bêcher date
est ici on est chez nous dans la maison
que nous avons en seine-et-marne à une
soixantaine de kilomètres de paris
aux confins de l'oise la maison mais pas
particulièrement belle mais elle est
confortable ici c'est je dois le dire
sérieusement ce la maison du bonheur
nous formons ma femme et moi un couple
heureux nous sommes une famille heureuse
avec nos trois enfants deux filles et un
garçon
louvre à wimmis net ça y est t'es
réveillé
ouais t'as bien dormi non pas très je
paye un bonnet qui a frappé mais je me
fais possible de dormir quand même ah
oui mais jamais il y avait un volet qui
sera payé mais mon choix mais mon décret
puisque ton ce matin
bello keller ida foule
ma femme s'appelle jacques une
marguerite marie alors je l'appelle
laura nous sommes mariés depuis 28 ans
je crois que l'on peut dire que nous
formons un ménage un bon ménage un
ménage unis je lui casse les pieds
depuis 28 ans alors elle a mérité
d'aller au paradis où que je sois dans
le monde du téléphone j'aime tout
particulièrement sa voix est aussi
difficile que soit le travail aussi
difficile que soit l'avis quelquefois
surtout loin d'elle dès que je lui ai
téléphoné dès que j'entends sa voix ce
serait mieux c'est au mieux elles
attendre juin faudrait un temps bruni
mais j'aime que tu me dises ces choses
là que tu l'aies pense de toute façon
alors mais tout le monde ne le dit pas
il y en a qui les pense qu'il me dise
pas ça me fait plaisir
l'entente
appelez on est là à appeler en et l'a
appelée on est là on nous appelle et
nous rappelons du pas de calais nous
appelons le bureau de poste de marquise
madame mes souliers à si vous êtes bien
bureaux de poste des marquises j'ai bien
le 32 11 16 à il doit démarrer mais
relevé numéros sont des choses qui
arrivent
maestro un peu de musique comme il
s'agit d'un semi automatique
donc ça ne peut être que 32 11 11
pourquoi 16 l'émission appelé on est là
doit plaire puisque le nombre des
auditeurs a fait plus que doubler depuis
le premier alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ces démissions et bien nous essayons de
rendre service aux gens les gens nous
appellent pour un tas de raisons et nous
nous rendrons compte en intervenant
auprès d'organismes publics ou privés
auprès d'administrations que la quantité
d'organismes en ce qu'ils peuvent faire
des dossiers rédiger des notes remplir
des formulaires demandé aux citoyens de
tout âges de toutes conditions sociales
de tous sexes de tout domicile de
remplir des formulaires des
questionnaires étaient verra pour
qu'ensuite cette paperasserie se perdent
et bien ce nombre est considérable avant
que par ces démissions
je ne répète lui qu'il y avait tellement
de dossiers est tellement de raison pour
qu'il se perde tellement moyens
dirais-je koné
oui et oui
est-il important pour les français de
connaître la fortune de leurs hommes
politiques on peut dire oui on veut dire
non on a souvent accusé les hommes
politiques de vider la poche des
français
peut-être qu'après avoir lu l'article du
nouvel observateur
nous dirons que nous les accusons
simplement de vider nos poches bien vous
m'avez on paye et appréhendé dans un
sens qui n'est pas bon on pousse on ne
peut pas appréhender me dit la fortune
des hommes politiques à plein des ouï
dire que m comprendre aussi les nouilles
internet préfet d'en appréhender en
général vous mais après ça c'est bon ce
que vous avez dix septième bout c'est
pas mal du tout c'est même bien
faisaient une bribe d'accent d'où
êtes-vous la corrèze
ah oui vraiment qu'on va beaucoup parler
tu entends par là encore nous avons 80
on parlera encore beaucoup je pense très
bien à l'homme mais après on fait même
l'espère que quand on parlera de la
corrèze on ne parlera pas d'appréhender
dans ce sens-là plomb les rires se
mettre au courant de ces arbres vous
avez employé dans un sens presque
presque englobant non j'ai enfin j'ai
voulu la prendre dans un sens d'
approche allant d'une chose on la
présente d'abord dans sombre dans sa
couleur dans un volume
oui et ma foi on regarde ses dimensions
on apprend une chose par
le volume qu'elle occupe dans l'espace
dans laquelle est placée m'appelle angle
objet la hauteur d'un corner la bourse
sur une cheminée par rapport aux lettres
à la cheminée nos rapports avec le soir
il m'arrive une fois ou deux par mois de
données et des cours à alips à
l'institut privé supérieur d'animation
ce sont des cours d'expression orale
j'apprends aux jeunes et quelquefois des
moins jeunes à ne pas faire trop de
fautes de français et à ne pas utiliser
des expressions qui ne sont pas
agréables à entendre surtout pour ceux
qui veulent ensuite exercé la profession
d'animateur dans divers domaines à
l'origine je me suis intéressé assez
court parce que j'y rencontrais
justement des jeunes et je n'ai jamais
voulu perdre le contact avec la jeunesse
j'ai des enfants qui ont maintenant 26
25 et 22 ans
j'ai toujours voulu comprendre ce que
pensait ce que voulaient les jeunes
alors ici c'est peut-être moi qui
prenait 10 on commence à lui maintenant
tu la boucle d'essais de patron dit de
pas trop rires vous parlez si vous
voulez mais tu essaies pas de pc le
patron ici cette vie ces gens semblent
laisser gens sans jouer à deux reprises
un très grand rôle dans ma vie d'abord
c'est le seul lycée où j'ai fait mes
études je suis resté ici depuis la 10e
jusqu'à mon second bachot les mettre les
enseignants étaient très bien je dois
dire il dispensait des enseignements de
qualité
les jeunes gens n'étaient pas toujours
très facile il y avait beaucoup de
gosses de riches beaucoup de fils à papa
et il s'amusait à marquer la différence
sociale
moi j'étais le fils d'un homme pauvre
mon père était à l'époque que commis
dans une épicerie ensuite il a travaillé
comme gérant de factures grille et nous
étions dans la gêne j'avais souvent
beaucoup de mal à amasser les cinq fonds
anciens bien sûr nécessaire pour aller
me faire couper les cheveux et il
s'amusait à faire des collectes de
pièces de monnaie aussi petit que
possible 5 centimes 10 centimes est
alors immense filet d'un paquet comme ça
en me disant tiens vieux va donc de
faire couper les tifs
c'est là quelque chose que je n'ai
jamais oublié j'ai toujours eu peur de
la pauvreté
j'ai l'angoissé de la misère et si
maintenant je travaille beaucoup peut
être trop au bout de
enfin c'est que j'ai la hantise de la
gêne je voudrais certainement pas le ton
dix centimes 10 centimes les mêmes vie
sentimentale et caméras vis en trois
semaines se garer des coquilles saint
jacques
voilà qui est bien moi je prendrais un
poisson une viande
je prendrai un blanc de turbo à l'aso
lange a dit monsieur paul
et ensuite t-bone stay que mirabaud mais
vous vendrez les autres choix parce que
sans sel sans sel sans beurre bien voilà
je nous ne vivons pas souvent ensemble
l'hymne ensemble je ne sais pas une fois
toutes les trois semaines
une fois par mois à tête à tête les
essayant de venir au café de la paix le
plus souvent possible parce que c'est un
endroit que nous aimons bien c'est le
lieu où nous nous sommes donné après
nous être connu notre deuxième à vivre
j'aime sortir pendant les deux années ou
presque où j'ai travaillé très tôt le
matin rpr au journal parlé il veut glue
couche très très tôt le soir je ne
pouvais pas sortir maintenant je sors tu
es un cinéma concerts principalement et
une fois de temps à autre un dîner je ne
suis pas gourmette
mais lorsque je sors avec ma femme j'ai
même endroit élégant et où l'on soit
bien pape doit parler lisant de ces
choses qui forme le fond est remplaçable
d'un bonheur j'aime bien jean louis
c'est un excellent forterre un homme qui
parle couramment le russe je crois le
français et d'autres langues qu'à une
protection convenable qui s'expriment
très convenablement
mon dieu moi que j'étais un excellent
reportage il a beaucoup de talent bien
sûr et je les écoute depuis toujours son
fonds pour la cause est juste estime que
l'esprit camia après les courses
explique moi je trouve que c'est très
bien
excessivement bien cultivé il connaît
beaucoup de chose n'est pas compris
qu'un on apprend certaines choses avec
lui et au point dans les cérémonies
officielles il est réellement
sensationnel c'est bien ses commentaires
ses commentaires aussi qu'il est un peu
content de lui mais pas à partager
il faut quand même admettre
via l'écran également bon c'est un homme
plaît quattro qui conçoit a l'air sympa
quoi proches prouve que c'est un homme
qui est intelligent il parle de
nombreuses langues
et quand il fait des reportages ce
merveilleux
toute sorte de reportage je trouve tout
bien mais surtout quand il fait ceux des
françaises drm
là c'est merveilleux parce que ça me
nuit m'ont jamais monument un chat blanc
manger mais ça c'est l'image même de ma
vie il ya d'abord une lutte permanente
contre le temps aujourd'hui je dispose
de 20 minutes au déjeuner alors je ne
vais pas m'amuser et à crier et à
houspiller deux garçons vite vite vite
on ne regarde déjà comme une bête
curieuse alors là ça créerait près ce
que ça peut paraître exagéré mais ça
crève est presque un petit scandale doré
d'éviter et puis il y à un mot régime
tous les ans du 15 octobre à peu près où
25 novembre
je suis un régime à haute dose de
protéines et a très peu de légumes
j'arrive à perdre comme ça en six
semaines quelque chose comme 7 à 8 kilos
s'est pas toujours très drôle ce qu'on
mange mais enfin vous bien obéir aux
ordres des médecins voient là et je suis
un malade un client extrêmement
attentifs aux prescriptions médicales
dors tu content voltaire est un ide
sourire voltige qu'il encore sur théo
décharné c'est la mostra célèbre peintre
aime 2007 à voltaire ce vol car si le
marbre d'oudon et qui se trouve au foyer
du public de la comédie française
tout enfant j'y venais j'ai vu tout le
répertoire est pas seulement une fois au
moins deux ou trois fois chaque pièce je
veux tout le répertoire classique ici à
la comédie française
nous faisions ma soeur qu'elle a sur lui
et moi nous faisions la queue galerie de
mont-joli ici tout près
nous faisons avec eux pour la
représentation de l'après midi et on
pouvait acheter pour trois francs au 4e
rang des places de par terre c'est à
dire les cinq derniers rangs des
fauteuils d'orchestre seulement pour
cela il fallait absolument faire avec
eux alors quand nous sortions de la
représentation de la matinée ma soeur
remettait en a que moi je filais à la
maison en métro je rapportais pour elle
et pour moi de sandwiches que ma mère
avait confectionné avec amour je me
glissais par la queue et nous
l'attendions encore une heure ou deux
pour acheter deux par terre dans la
représentation du soir
je n'ai jamais oublié ce temps là et je
crois que le fait d'aller souvent à la
comédie française a eu une influence sur
ma manière de parler
on me reproche je ne dis pas que leur
projet team immérité mes enfants me
reproche de parler d'une manière
quelquefois un peu pour les ché peut
être aussi quelques fois un peu
redondante
alors ça c'est le revers de la médaille
je crois que inconsciemment mais en
toute certitude les textes que
j'entendais ici à la comédie française
ont marqué une empreinte sur ma manière
de parler c'est ainsi je préfère
d'ailleurs parler quelques fois un peu
trop bien même si certaines règles que
le paraît trop mal de nos jours les gens
qui devraient faire profession de parler
bien c'est à dire tous mes confrères de
la radio de la télévision se laisse
facilement aller et l'on entend des
bourdes et on entend des choses
abominables
on ne respecte plus assez les français
la langue française et c'est dommage
voilà la comédie française
j'aurais bien aimé devenir pensionnaire
puis sociétaires mais je voulais aussi
faire une carrière de coureur cycliste
parce que j'ai toujours été un fan
atiques du cyclisme et vers ma vingtième
année j'ai eu une des grandes déceptions
de mon existence
j'ai compris qu'en tout et pour tout
tout ce que je pouvais songé à devenir
c'était d'être cyclistes à la comédie
française
cruelle déception
j'aime marcher seul et j'aime marcher
danser ou après il y en a marre de vous
voyez juste au bord de la rivière
il me dirait 6020 s'il me dit non aux
sources
pas si c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
celui ci que je réfléchissais l'issic je
prends toutes mes décisions importantes
pour réfléchir je vous faire un aveu
j'ai besoin d'être dans un lieu
découvert de manière à me parler à moi
même je me parlent et je me réponds
c'est un péché mignon c'est d'ici que
j'ai pris toutes les décisions qui ont
compté ces dernières années dans la vie
c'est d'ici par exemple que je me suis
dit que je n'accepterais pas les
propositions qui m'était faite de faire
du théâtre peut-être ai-je eu top
enfin j'ai encore toute ma vie devant
moi c'est d'ici que j'ai décidé de
demander un congé de deux ans à la
télévision au moment de la partition de
rtf de manière à pouvoir faire de la
radio rtl où l'on paye mieux ce n'est un
secret pour personne
c'est ici que j'ai décidé il y a trois
ou quatre mois de terminer mon congé rtl
et de revenir à plein temps à tf1 en
réalité cette île qui n'est rien ce bord
de marne qui qui ne représentera
extraordinaire c'est si je devais écrire
ma biographie et bien il y aurait
plusieurs chapitres qui se passera ici
voilà c'est mon mieux penser
je voudrais cessé de vivre aux rythmes
terriblement dur de la télévision
quotidienne maintenant et je réussis sur
le 1er division ce n'est pas à moi de
juger si j'ai réussi c'est uniquement
par mon travail
les peaux de banane ne m'ont jamais
manqué j'appartiens aucune coterie
j'appartiens aucun parti politique je
n'appartiens à aucun groupe de pression
j'ai énormément travaillé
je ne pense pas que l'on puisse dans le
monde actuel et à moins d'avoir un papa
très riche derrière soi je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse gagner confortablement sa
vie sans travailler beaucoup
je ne vais pas que de l'audiovisuel
j'écris j'écris des livres j'en ai une
case elle déjà mon rectifier et j'écris
des articles toutes les semaines un
article pour les paris hippiques jaune
de france soir et une trentaine de fois
par an une longue interview en général
d'une jolie femme ou des personnalités
du cinéma d'un jour de france j'écris je
suis très exigeant à l'égard de moi même
je suis toujours exigeant pour moi même
et mon livre de chevet le voici ces deux
dictionnaires de difficultés de la
langue française il est rare que je
reste deux ou trois jours sans l'ouvrir
et sans en lire quelques pages c'est
fort utile cela vie et de quelle forme
de journalisme s'agit-il
je suis un peu gêné je n'aime pas le
journalisme ultramoderne qui consiste à
ouvrir des alcôves ou à soulever la jupe
des dames et à regarder ce qu'il ya en
dessous
et puis il ya une autre forme de
journalisme verrez qu'elle je ne suis
pas attirée c'est le journalisme
politique engagée
je n'aime pas tellement la politique je
n'aime pas la politique intérieure
j'aime et je comprends bien la politique
étrangère mais je ne suis pas certain
que ce soit un sujet et que le public
aime beaucoup et puis il y a le
journalisme de la catastrophe je n'aime
pas le mistral arrive à l'heure 364
jours par an on n'en dit rien mais le
365e jours il a vingt minutes de retard
alors
en fait des tartines comme ça des titres
comme ça on dit dans la presse actuelle
good news no news c'est à dire bonne
nouvelle pas de nouvelles non moi je
crois qu'une bonne nouvelle c'est
également une nouvelle mais enfin ça ne
correspond guère aux goûts du public
actuel alors l'audiovisuel la radio ou
la télévision parlons surtout télévision
les gens ci-100 spécialisés chacun de
mes confrères à sa branche il a sa
partie moi non
ma spécialité en fait c'est de ne pas en
avoir tous deux mais tout de même je me
suis toujours occupé de sport j'aime
qu'augmenter le patinage a commenté le
cyclisme
j'aime qu'augmenter le concours hippique
j'aime commenter les courses ne peut
être un peu moins d'ailleurs ce n'est
plus moi qui les commande sur tf1 c'est
vos confrères theron je le remplace deux
à trois fois par an je commente une
dizaine de tirs c'est au lieu d'une
quarantaine j'ai toujours fait les
reportages de ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler les cérémonies officielles
le mariage de la princesse anne où les
obsèques de franco ou la prestation de
serment du roi juan carlos
si le prince de galles se marient je
pense que j'irai faire ce reportage
la revue de la flotte française il ya
quelques mois en méditerranée le 14
juillet il y à une quinzaine de jours le
11 novembre bon et puis je crois que
désormais je ferais davantage de ce que
l'on pourrait appeler de grandes
émissions on me propose à tf1 une série
d'émissions historique
je songe à quelque chose sur
l'anniversaire de la mort de louis saez
je change aussi un thème qui serait est
ce que la france ne souffre pas trop de
l'hypercentralisation que lui a imposée
il ya trois siècles le cardinal de
richelieu
vous voyez j'ai voulu je voudrais faire
un peu moins de télévision quotidiennes
bien sûr il m'arrivera de faire un sujet
pour le journal télévisé
j'aime cela je travaillais pour le
journal pendant 20 ans je présentais
4000 fois le journal télévisé peut-être
4500 leurs fraises je n'en sais rien ce
qu'il présente je songe
roger gicquel je songe à yves mourousi à
je songe à jean claude bourret le font
très bien
moi je crois que je vais changer de
registre et devenir plus sérieux non pas
plus sérieux dans mon travail lui même
j'ai toujours été sérieux je crois je
sais pas vous mais des foules des arbres
la colère etc
mais enfin je pense que si j'ai une
qualité c'est celle d'être sérieux mais
enfin ce n'est pas la manière de faire
qui deviendra plus sérieuse c'est des
sujets peut-être qu'ils seront moins
moins pimpant mois - bulles de savon je
voudrais aller davantage au fond des
choses
voilà comment je vois les trois ou
quatre années qu'il me reste avant la
retraite à accomplir la télévision